wann haben Sie zuletzt Sahra Wagenknecht
gesprochen
das muss vor der Sommerpause gewesen
sein nächste Woche spreche ich sie
wieder und worüber haben Sie gesprochen
über ihre Idee eine neue Partei zu
gründen oder bitte die nächste Frage
ja natürlich haben wir darüber
gesprochen
weil ich den Weg für falsch halte ich
halte Abspaltung überhaupt für falsch
und ich war ja mal in einer als Partei
und bin jetzt von einer von bispartei zu
sein da hat sie ihren Platz habe ich
meinen Platz und immer wenn man sich
abspeichert und man denkt man baut was
Eigenes auf was nur auf die eigene
Person zugerichtet ist
in der Regel scheitert es und man darf
dann auch die Mandate nicht mitnehmen
denn sie ist ja für diese Partei auch
wenn sie sie kritisch sieht aber sie sah
sie ja schon vorher war sehr kritisch in
den Bundestag gewählt worden also wir
sprechen über verschiedene Dinge ich
versuche es ihr auszureden ich weiß
natürlich nicht ob es mir gelingt und
wenn nicht dann bin ich aber auch wieder
bereit um die Existenz der Partei zu
kämpfen müssen die hatte schon so viele
Krisen ja die Linksparteien ja meine
mein mechanisch die anderen die können
ja Krisen haben so viel Sie wollen also
natürlich 89 eine Existenzkrise dann
wurden wir politisch moralisch
ausgesetzt haben wir überstanden da hat
man versucht mit falschen
Steuerbescheiden uns auszuschalten aber
auch überstanden und haben sich ein paar
Dinge gesagt na gut wenn es die gegen
eine schaffen müssen wir das selbst
erledigen die Partei jetzt zu erledigen
ja das kann ich nicht akzeptieren ja das
ist ja hart für Sie oder ich meine ich
darf das ausnahmsweise mal sagen soll
nicht Alter das rassistisch klingt sie
sind aber 75 so und sie haben gesagt
nach
Herzinfarkten und einer Gehirnoperation
ich bin durch ich mache das nicht mehr
das heißt sie haben gar keine Chance
mehr dort irgendwie wirklich
einzugreifen das Ding rumzureißen gibt
ja Leute die sagen der Gisi muss jetzt
noch mal ran weil sonst ist die Linke
tatsächlich Geschichte haben sie Angst
davor nein das nicht meine historische
Aufgabe war eine andere meine
historische Aufgabe bestand darin die
Ostdeutschen in ihren Interessen zu
vertreten die die Einheit nicht wollten
die aus deutschen zu vertreten die die
Einheiten
ja diejenigen die sie vielleicht wollten
aber die wussten dass aus ihnen nichts
wird und dann kam eine ganz große Gruppe
hinzu die dachten dass das irgendwas
wird aussehen aber nichts wurde das
waren die enttäuschten und es gab ja
keine andere Partei und auch keine
andere Person die bereit war einerseits
ihn zu sagen ihr müsst auch etwas
selbstkritisch eure Biografien
aufarbeiten andererseits aber bereits
bei ihrer Interessen zu vertreten weil
sie ja auch einen Weg in die Einheit
finden mussten sie dafür ich mir heute
Abgeordnete anderer Parteien dass ich
mich dafür auch noch habe so beschimpfen
lassen was ich gar nicht wusste es dass
ich preußisch stur bin aber ich kann da
nicht gehen also das war schon das war
meiner historische Aufgabe das dabei
noch herausgekommen ist dass es nach
vielen Jahrzehnten wieder links von der
SPD eine Partei im Bundestag gab fand
ich auch ganz nett inzwischen haben die
Menschen sich daran gewöhnt und deshalb
sollte sie nicht kaputt gehen aber ich
mache nicht wieder an Fraktionsvorsitz
okay ich bin 75 hatte drei im Fahrzeug
also man muss auch Grenzen kennen aber
ich bemühe mich wissen was ich jetzt
wieder mache ich frag mich durchs Land
und mache überall Partei Versammlung und
spreche mit den Genossen und genossen
wie wir uns nun so einer Situation
verhalten sollen so und da kommt das
Sarah Wagenknecht und Fragen sagen die
kann aus dem Stand 19 20% machen macht
ihn das Angst nein sie wird wenn sie
wirklich diesen Weg geht den ich habe
für falsch Alter aber wenn Sie glauben
ich befürchte es auch trotzdem werde ich
aber mit ihr reden und versuchen es ja
auszur wenn sie den Weg geht wird sie
bei der Europawahl erfordert erfolgreich
sein vielleicht noch bei den
Landtagswahlen im Osten im nächsten Jahr
aber nach meiner festen Überzeugung bei
der Bundestagswahl 2025 nicht aufstehen
was war das ach was war los 250 anderen
Zeitschriften nicht gut organisiert man
sieht die Lehren daraus man sagt ich
brauche
wenn sie etwas nicht kann ist es
organisieren deswegen sagt sie auch
mache ich gar nicht mehr selber macht
immer wenn Sie ein Manager hat der kann
ausfallen auch sie kann ausfallen das
ist alles immer auf eine Person gelenkt
das ist äußerst schwierig kann ich habe
damit ja Erfahrung wir haben aus dem
Stand heraus versucht Landesverbände im
Westen aufzumachen wir bekamen gute
Mitglieder aber auch lauter ausgegrenzte
die sind dann auch wie ausgegrenzte ich
kann nur sagen viel Vergnügen also vor
allen Dingen darf sie die Mandate nicht
mitnehmen denn sie ist ja für diese
linke und nicht für eine Partei und die
Linke tot zu machen in dem Bundestag
gewählt worden wahrscheinlich wird es
trotzdem machen
aber ich werde versuchen es ja
auszureden dann habe ich diesen
bezüglich meine Schuldigkeit getan und
ich werde versuchen wir mit dir und
damit natürlich auch auf dafür zu
gewinnen dass wir dann um die Linke
kämpfen wenn Sie diesen Fehler begehen
daran darf sie nicht starten mich
interessiert nur mal ganz kurz die
Meinung von Feldmann in dem Zusammenhang
die sagt ich finde es gut wenn wenn Frau
Wagen nicht machen würde also ich finde
es
vom Vorteil wenn im Sammelbecken der
unzufriedenen mehrere Fischen weil es
ist so dass in der Mehrheitsgesellschaft
müssen sich Parteien ständig gegenseitig
bekämpfen sie müssen um ihre Wähler
kämpfen die AFD hat in dem Kampf um die
Unzufriedenen kein Konkurrenz und
Konkurrenz tut immer gut eigentlich also
wir sollten Konkurrenz stiften wollen
dennoch halte ich Sarah Wagenknecht
nicht für ungefährlich also sie macht
mir schon Angst als Persönlichkeit auch
als also die Art und Weise wie sie
Politik macht macht mir manchmal Angst
warum weil sie sie erzählt manchmal ein
narrativ das vielleicht früher noch
stimmte jetzt aber nicht mehr stimmt zum
Beispiel sie saß in diese Sendung vor
kurzem und hat erzählt
dass man kann ja nicht erwarten dass die
Leute ihr Autos stehen lassen weil die
Deutsche Bahn ist eine Katastrophe aber
kurz davor hat Herr Volker Wissing eine
riesen Investitionssumme angekündigt und
ein ganz krassen Plan entwickelt wie die
Deutsche Bahn jetzt ganz schnell und
ausführlich aufgewertet werden soll und
dann habe ich mir gefragt es kann ja
nicht sein dass dir das nicht weiß das
heißt es kann aber auch nicht sein dass
Volker Wissing das selber glaubt ne dass
die Deutsche Bahn ganz schnell
aufgerüstet werden kann aber ist jetzt
ein klar den Plan gibt
aber es gibt keinen und sie würde den
Plan aber entwerfen und das finde ich
gefährlich
meine Partei hat den Fehler begangen
nach der Vereinigung mit der wir es geht
sich auf den Westen zu konzentrieren und
den Osten zu vernachlässigen und da ist
die AFD eingestiegen das haben sie aber
inzwischen begriffen und verstanden und
wir kümmern uns jetzt wieder anders
der Psychiater darauf wie schaut Manfred
Lutz darauf was passiert da gerade also
woher kommt diese Befindlichkeit es gibt
ja offensichtlich viele Menschen die
sich obwohl wir immer mehr Parteien
haben an keiner Stelle wiederfinden und
sagen
ja und ich muss irgendwie meine
Unzufriedenheit dokumentieren also ich
habe keine definitive Meinung zu der zu
der Frage bin aber eigentlich
ähnlich wie Frau Feldmann der Meinung es
wäre ganz gut wenn die Unzufriedenen
noch eine andere Möglichkeit hätten ich
finde die AFD deswegen wirklich
gefährlich weil sie nach rechts außen
offen ist die ist einfach offen und sich
da auch Stimmen zu holen ich glaube
nicht dass das alle AFD Wähler und ich
glaube noch nicht mal alle AFD
Mitglieder rechts extrem sind glaube ich
schon die sind zum Teil auch naiv und
ich weiß nicht was alles Sachen nicht
zufrieden aber die Gefahr dieser Partei
ist dass sie prinzipiell eigentlich
gegen Rechtsextreme wenn überhaupt ganz
spät reagieren und versuchen diese ganze
grün diese ganze braune Soße mit
sozusagen mitzunehmen und das halte ich
für gefährlich und deswegen wäre mir
eine sozusagen eine andere Partei der
unzufriedenen lieber die diese Offenheit
ins rechtsradikale nicht hätte das
nämlich ganz kurz was dazu sagen der
höcke ist offen rechtsextreme und sie
machen nichts gegen ihn ein Gegenteil
das zweite ist sie haben Recht der
Bevölkerungsanteil der der etablierten
Politik von der CSU bis einschließlich
der Linken nicht mehr über den Weg traut
wächst das waren zur Bundestagswahl
38,5% der Erwachsenen deutsche
Bevölkerung und Soziologinnen und
Soziologen sagen mir die Zahl nimmt
ständig zu aber was Sache wenn sie ich
hoffe ja nicht aber wenn Sie die eigene
Partei gründen müssen Flüchtlinge ein
bisschen wie die AFD meint
Wirtschaftspolitik wie Ludwig Erhardt
und sozial wie die Linken und diese
versucht diese Mischung anzubieten führt
meistens zu Verlusten die einen Willen
dich aus dem und nicht die anderen aus
einem anderen Grund nicht das ist immer
so eine Illusion dass man sagt ich mache
jetzt meine Mischung und mit dieser
Mischung bin ich ja erfolgreich
und das Ergebnis war wir haben weniger
Stimmen bekommen
keine Wahlkampfkosten Erstattung
bekommen weil die anderen linken sich
geweigert haben ihre vermögensverhältnis
eine blanke Katastrophe kann
die gegenerfahrung das wenn man in einer
Partei ganz verschiedene Aspekte hat in
den Volksparteien z.B bei der bei der
CDU war das so die hatten
Wirtschaftsflügel der war eben Ludwig
Erhard die hatten oder haben Sie ja
immer noch ein sozialflügel die waren da
ganz anders orientiert es ist auch nicht
schlecht wenn man sozusagen so ein
bisschen Kramladen von verschiedenen
Sachen hat
braucht nur überzeugende Personen die
das auch repräsentieren da ist natürlich
sehr die Frage ob eine neue aufgemachte
Partei die wir sie gerade gesagt hat nur
auf eine Person orientiert ist diese
Person überhaupt zusammen bekommt die
das auch irgendwie überzeugend
einigermaßen dachte ich glaube das
Grundproblem war das
Grundform dass in der merkelzeit die
klassischen Parteien eigentlich ja kaum
mehr unterscheidbar war und ich fand es
katastrophal dass in Talkshows wenn man
irgendeine Gegenstimme hatte man muss
sich ja mal vorstellen die hat eine
große Koalition aber jeder wusste die
FDP und die Grünen hätten auch gerne mit
regiert damit war nur noch die AFD
sozusagen für eine Talkshow überhaupt
geeignet als wirkliche Gegend und
Position und das hat sie auch mit groß
gemacht ich habe die Linken aber die AFD
hat sich dann wirklich populistisch
durchgesetzt wobei ich auch den Ausdruck
Populismus inzwischen nicht mehr gut
finde der diskriminierend eingesetzt
wird
Demokratie kommt von Demos das heißt
griechisch voll
Populismus kommt von populus das heißt
lateinisch Volk wenn unsere Politiker
nicht mehr dem Volk aufs Maul schauen
und nicht mehr das sagen was das Volk
versteht und wo die denn das Volk den
Eindruck hat die vertreten unsere
Meinung dann gewinnt die AFD immer mehr
Stimmen so schade
unsere sich aber anwesende Frau auch mal
was sagen muss und dann würde ich gerne
noch kurz etwas dagegen sagen ich soll
noch was sagen zum Thema AFD also ich
habe wie Sie Herr Gisi eine ein
persönliches Gewicht in diesem Gespräch
ich habe jüdischen Hintergrund und das
heißt dass meine Auseinandersetzungen
mit der AFD auf kollektive Ebene oft
sehr verletzende sind weil ich oft
angegriffen werde aufgrund meines
jüdisch Seins
andersrum habe ich ein paar Erfahrungen
auf individuelle Ebene machen dürfen mit
Menschen die sich aus welchem Grund auch
immer mit der AFD in Verbindung gesetzt
haben oder für die afd-politik machen
oder für die AFD wählen und ich habe
irgendwann verstanden dass das
kollektivbild AFD hat wenig mit das
individuelle Bild von AFD zu tun und
wenn ich sage individuelle Bild ich
meine sagen wir mal irgendwelchen Mann
auf irgendwelchen kleinen Dorf mit einem
nirgendwo und das Dorf geht irgendwie
zugrunde und er versucht es mit den
Mehrheitsparteien dass da was passiert
und niemand schaut da überhaupt rein und
der der fürs Dorf zuständig ist war nie
da und dann sieht er die AFD als einzige
Möglichkeit auf kommunale eben etwas zu
erreichen und dann sagt er mir was habe
ich denn mit höcke zu tun ich
interessiere mich nur für mein Dorf und
dann merke ich dass es doch eine gewisse
[Musik]
zweistufigkeit gibt es gibt AFD als
Kollektiv und das davor habe ich sehr
Angst wirklich sehr Angst also ist echt
schwierig drüber zu reden aber es gibt
das Individuum und das Individuum ist
kein starkes Objekt statisches Objekt
das Individuum ändert sich ständig in
kann morgen ganz anders sein als heute
und mit diesem Individuum haben wir noch
Chancen und diese Parteien die so viel
an die AFD abgegeben haben wie sie sehr
gut beschrieben haben Herr Lutz sie
müssen sich mit diesen Individuen
auseinandersetzen und sie mussten
deswegen weil sie wollen das war
interessanter Moment sie sagten als Herr
Lutz anfing über die AFD und ihre Wähler
zu sprechen sagten sie direkt Björn
höcke und ich dachte ich würde das
anders unterscheiden ich unterscheide
immer sehr genau zwischen
afd-funktionären und ihren Wählern weil
ich bei den Funktionären paar sehr
unappetitliche Leute dabei sind
tatsächlich aber auch nicht nur und in
bei den Wählern würde ich sagen da ist
ja die ganz große Frage wie sollte man
damit um Manfred Lutz Vertreter die
Position und sagt wir können nicht mit
einem Fünftel quasi der Bevölkerung oder
in Ostern nicht reden deshalb völlig
klar das ist ja voll so klar ist das
nicht ich will ja aber nur folgendes
haben bei den 38,5 Prozent das sind 20
Prozent die gar nicht wählen gehen Null
Vertrauen haben ein Prozent die
absichtlich ungültig werden 8,7 Prozent
die wählen ganz kleine Parteien die
wissen sowieso dass sie nicht einziehen
sie wollen nur sie Betreuer Christen
dass sie nichts mit den etablierten
Parteien zu tun haben und bundesweit
waren damals zehn Prozent jetzt werden
es ja mehr sein die die AFD wählen und
zwar auch um der etablierten Politik zu
sagen wie unzufrieden sind und jetzt
kommt meine Kritik an allen etablierten
Parteien
sie reden immer nur darüber was die AFD
macht wie sie es macht und nicht über
unsere Fehler ja die ist ermöglicht
haben dass die AFD so stark ein Thema
und es gibt kein Gesprächskreis zwischen
CSU CDU SPD FDP Bündnis 90 grün und den
linken wo man sich mal darüber enthält
unterhält wie man wieder Vertrauen bei
der Bevölkerung gewinnt ich sage immer
zwei Beispiele erstens die falsche
Sprache sie sprechen eben gerne über die
veräußerungs Gewinnsteuer erklären
überhaupt nicht was das ist quatschen
einfach kariert 95% der Leute wissen gar
nicht was das sein soll das zweite ist
wenn heute FDP grün und SPD Entscheidung
treffen dann lautet der zweite
Tagesordnungspunkt wie verkaufen wir es
an die Bevölkerung das kann mal der
wareburg Beweggrund sein oft aber nicht
weil man sich eben überlegt was könnte
eine Mehrheit akzeptieren ich habe mal
gesagt die Politiker sagen nicht alles
weil es nicht um Wahrheit sondern um
Mehrheiten geht und das ist zu einem
Strukturfehler geworden
Fehler und darüber diskutieren wir nicht
mit einem Mann und gerade wenn man wie
ich 75 ist kann man sich das wirklich
leisten so eine Gesprächsrunde auch zu
öffnen auch mal den anderen zuzuhören
aber es ist alles so kleinkariert es ist
alles so ich kriege da ein paar Stimmen
mehr und du kriegst da ein paar Stimmen
mehr mein Gott das geht mir so oft die
Nerven ich kann das kaum bestellen
werden
das stimmt aber verstehen sie das ist
nein das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht
weil wir die Demokratie Gefährten wenn
wir nicht die Leute wieder gewinnen wenn
sie nicht wieder ein Vertrauen bekommen
und so wie sich die etablierten Parteien
zur Zeit benehmen und bewegen wenn wir
das Vertrauen ich glaube nicht daran
dass eine tatsächlich so ein
gesprächstress sinnvoll wäre im
Gegenteil ich glaube dass das wieder den
Eindruck vermittelt die alle gemeinsam
mit mir teilgenommen ich
ich glaube es reicht wenn es mal einen
Politiker gibt der sagt ich habe einen
Fehler gemacht und das war nicht richtig
und so oder wenn es mal ein paar
Politiker gibt die auch ich glaube wir
sind in der Situation man kann eine
Partei eine gefährlich
rechtsorientierte Partei wenn sie drei
Prozent hat ausgrenzen einfach nicht mit
den reden so lange nicht mit den Reden
hat man bei den Republikanern damals
gemacht das hat auch geklappt die sind
dann verschwunden aber eine Partei wo
35% in Sachsen diese Partei wählen da
muss man die Methode ändern Paul
Watzlawick Kommunikationswissenschaftler
hat gesagt man wenn man immer mehr
dasselben von dem tut was nicht
funktioniert hat man ein Problem wir
grenzen uns ab jeder der erwischt wird
man mit dem AFD Menschen geredet zu
haben wird sofort an den Pranger
gestellt ich glaube wir müssten
tatsächlich wir auch die Politiker
müssen mit AFD Leuten mit wählen auch
mit funktionieren reden denn wir haben
ja Argumente wir haben ja Argumente aber
der Eindruck entsteht t man redet gar
nicht mit denen jeder redet und das
finde große Problem der Gesellschaft im
Moment nur mit dem eigenen Stammtisch
und der eigene Stammtisch da zeigt man
wie tapfer man gegen die AFD ist und
sowas
und so weiter
das heißt man sagt immer wieder dasselbe
und das seit Jahren schon und das
Ergebnis sind 35 Prozent in Sachsen Herr
Lust zu deinem Punkt haben sie wirklich
Unrecht es gibt solche Gesprächskreise
nicht und das hat Gründe dass es ihnen
nicht gibt wenn es sie gäbe ginge es gar
nicht darum was auszuhangeln sondern
unter Ausfluss der Öffentlichkeit sich
mal über die Fehler zu unterhalten und
auch darüber wie man zu den Fehlern
steht und offen damit umgeht das muss
ich Buderus lassen als Ministerpräsident
sich hingestellt und hat gesagt ich habe
mich gehört
das angeht eine ziemliche Ausnahme ja
und deshalb treffe ich jetzt einen
anderen habe ich noch nie gehört von
einem anderen Ministerpräsident man
redet immer drumherum
genau
finde ich müssten wir lernen unser
Verhalten zu ändern und dann haben sie
recht also mit Wählerinnen und Wählern
immer nicht nur in der Sprechstunde für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sondern auch bei
Kundgebung oder bei Diskussion da kommen
die ja einfach hin und melden sich und
quatschen das halte ich schon aus da bin
ich
sorgenfrei war es eins und da haben sie
recht so ein richtige wahre sichere
Methode wie man den Rechtsextremismus
klein macht den Nationalismus weltweit
klein macht ich bitte Sie denken Sie an
Trump denken Sie an Erdogan denken Sie
an du da an urban ein Meloni erzählt das
ist ja keine rein deutsche Erscheinung
wir haben eine pennen in Frankreich wir
haben überhaupt diese Entwicklung weil
die Menschen Angst vor der
Globalisierung kam und der Nationalismus
und Rechtsextremismus nutzt diese Angst
und behauptet er kriegt national alles
geklärt was natürlich Unsinn ist ich
fange an mich aufzuhören gleich auf aber
im Augenblick gar nicht mein Problem
aber ich stimme Ihnen zu die wirkliche
Methode wie wir das erfolgreich
zurückdrängen ist noch niemanden
eingefallen